[Applause]
well
how did you know she was there how do
you what whoa
what
wait a minute
oh my god there has to be something
going on there because like my god what
what oh
you joked he was your cousin he actually
is
oh cousin skeet skeet skeeter
[Laughter]
welcome back to new rockstars miss
marvel kamala khan just woke up to the
disturbing truth that sometimes your
great grandmother from your visions is
the same woman as your crush's mama is
kamala in love with her grand uncle what
is going on
what is going on right now man i don't
know
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's official after show for ms
marvel on disney plus i'm eric voss my
easter egg breakdown of this episode is
coming later today right now to discuss
this episode with me is empty empty how
are you feeling are you are you hanging
in there after this
we need to talk to the illuminat aunties
right now because i need explanation i
need answers and the illuminati's know
uh everything yes they know everything i
feel like they are smarter and know more
about how things really work than the
838 illuminati i think that's for sure
right you can't kill these
you trying to get one to maximoff to
take apart these illuminati's and she's
not going to stand a chance
seriously i want the post credit of this
series to be more dough but just be like
hello luma aunties i have five available
chairs
and they're just like six we don't need
you get out of here get out of here get
out of here
i want them to be in charge i mean i
know they're conspiracy theorists but so
is the illuminati like they don't know
right there illuminati's full of liars
why not these ladies they you gotta know
your control all right let's let's
quickly recap what happened this episode
so uh kamala tests out her powers with
bruno and they discovered some cryptic
writing on the bengal uh
might be arabic might be urdu i love how
uh kamala knows the language of her
who's spoken but she's not as much of a
student like uh what's it the pious boys
of the of the muslim community in jersey
city she can't read it it's just like
it's some cryptic writing that could be
anything really i assume we'll find out
soon
uh but we get this interesting line from
bruno's insane biometric tech
let's just you know overlook that for a
second the guy has like biometric
scanners from his tablet of like being
able to read her dna
this guy doesn't need to go to caltech
this guy needs to be like running you
know everything he needs she's a
professor
what the heck to be partnering with
shuri to build new uh vibranium tech
because this guy yeah
now in the top three smartest uh
engineers in the mcu i i think but he's
able to determine that this hard light
is coming from within her a bit of a
cheesy line i gotta say it's coming from
inside you even the editing of that
scene is like moving on
but uh but yes the bangle is unlocking a
power that is in her dna which is a very
very very importance right it's not just
coming from the bangles coming from
within her uh but kamala and nakia
attend some mosque services where nakia
decides to run for the board to improve
the conditions for the women's
facilities
democracy
go for it and ikea i have some questions
about like what is this subplot just
like part of the the y a genre the
coming of age that's kind of what it
feels like to me i'm not going to read
into this any more than that it's
wonderful to watch to get to know this
community and how they operate and and
i'm all on board for it but i'm not
going to say like is she actually a
skrull is she actually going to be part
of the grc at some point no not
interested i just like it for what it is
to be honest with you i love nakia she's
a great character she's a great friend
great like what a wonderful friend uh
and like she it's just as immature as
kamala is but like also wise beyond her
years and you just want to see her
succeed and when we see them at uh zoe's
party it's just we get this great like
scott pilgrim meets fast times at
richmond moment with
diving in the pool getting out of the
pool bruno man my eyes are on bruno this
whole scene because i'm like bruno i've
been there i've been there
bro
i i never had abs my entire life but at
some point some kids in high school some
of these guys just like hit their growth
spurt at the right time and are just
like just have a swimmer's body or some
kind of athlete's body and they never
did anything some of these kids they
just had abs they were skinny enough and
had abs i never had abs i had a uh sugar
cookie plump rolls that's all i've had
my entire life
so like i remember feeling that like
how did these kids just actually look
like
seriously like why are you here why
don't you just be a model somewhere get
out of here yeah get out of here get out
of jersey city we wear layers here it's
freezing out why do you have to take
your shirt off
bruno and of course bruno's a little
stinker too he's like she crashed her
car
i like this movie too
get in the back backseat bruno this is
about you right now i get it i feel you
but it's not about you should have tried
harder
you should've you should have tried
harder
but it's not it's okay bruno go over to
caltech man good to go
you know she left her gloves in the
bathroom she don't care about you that
much bruno you're a cow tech but that's
right that's right the cops show up bust
the party so they flee with camera and
he's got his nice car they talk about
some bollywood films bruno's pretending
he likes the bollywood films he's just
heard of them he's probably read the
imdb titles and things he's an expert
now no sorry man this is about you um uh
my favorite moment this episode kamala
going home dancing with delight to the
ronnettes be my baby like this is like
the kind of [ __ ] we need to see more of
in the mcu just like people geeking out
this is why i love disney plus series
because we get these story beats and
these characters just get to dance
around their house with goofy lights
and we get these needle drops it's
it's such a wonderful moment and like
this is something i used to do as a kid
i would literally put on music and just
dance around i mean for me it was
usually like show tunes in disney
soundtracks like i put on uh uh uh phil
collins tarzan soundtrack and
cry that was that was high school for me
that was high school for me i would uh i
love to sing along to your randy newman
uh from the soundtrack to toy story
straights
things are happening to me that was
puberty uh that was
[Music]
show you and i are just singing the
goofy [ __ ] that we said when we were
45 minutes of this please every week
inside disney songs
fun fact about the ronettes be my baby
ronnie spector abused horribly by phil
spector who's a psycho who's now in jail
because he loves playing russian
roulette
oh it's amazing she was able to get out
of that that guy is crazy mr wallace
sound phil spector behind some of the
best uh 60s songs that you've ever heard
including be my baby credited on this
episode of miss marvel he's a criminal
with a psycho who who killed a future
wife uh killed whatever he went to jail
for whatever he's convicted now but
now you pulled the trigger bang she died
he did it this guy's nuts ronnie specter
you can hear the pain in her voice when
she sings her songs because that's what
she went home to every night
yikes but that's the truth there's
always a dark truth
never never uh google your heroes well
i'll just say that never do it or meet
them
great artist bad person
anywho
this uh you know wonderful uh coming of
age tale uh manifests in this hilarious
way of the hard light glowing like a zit
on come on his nose yeah you get this
great moment of just like her handing
her a tampon in the in the bathroom just
this great euphoria heart to heart but
unlike euphoria it's just it's just
wholesome and not like the people trying
to kill each other i uh
yes between this show and euphoria like
high school is now the present for me it
was buried in the house
i never went to public high school so
like shows like euphoria and this are
like my only windows into public school
so i'm just like wow was it this extreme
jesus christ
yeah it was extreme it was extreme and
they used crazy lighting and transitions
in the background through the halls
i believe it
and then everyone was like a smoke show
everyone was that i believe it um i my
only look into a public school was uh
zoey 101 for the longest time um i was
like oh my god those kids are living
large
that's wholesome that is wholesome
that's what it should be
uh that in uh degrassi next generation
anyway okay so bruno gets accepted to
caltech uh but kamala just blows him off
um doesn't want to do another training
session she's good i don't need to be a
superhero there's a cute boy who wants
to drive me around and he might be
related to me it's like not hot enough
bruno sorry
[Music]
we don't talk about you she and cameron
talk about some bollywood stars i heard
kingo get dropped there uh famous each
hollywood superstar and then her brother
amir and his uh fiancee spot them they
pretend kamala does that cameron is a
cousin oh wow all right you are
so then we get this amazing scene over
dinner yusuf and minima talk about some
family history and this is a they do
this a lot in movies where the family
has like the family stories that they
tell but it's totally forced exposition
they do this in back to the future where
it's like
had it not been for him we never would
have fallen in love like these things
that's just like oh so this is actually
important but it sounds like how about
umt my family never really talked legit
but i understand that families have
stories like this i
i'm not criticizing this i love this in
movies because you gotta force in you
kind of forcing some exposition somehow
and i just like seeing families kind of
tell each other stories
oh yeah i do like a good family story
like my family wasn't like super super
like close growing up so like whenever i
see like little family stories where
like families getting along which is one
of my favorite parts of the show is just
seeing kamala's family just
be a family unit i'm like wow this is so
wholesome and like your dad's amazing
your mom's like you know strict but she
cares about you i'm just like it's just
i don't know this is nice so i do i did
like that moment but it is it did feel
like all right you got to remember this
for later wink wink um sort of moment so
yeah
we learned about muniba's mother and her
grandmother a little bit during the part
during the partition between india and
pakistan
absolutely look into that history
because it's heartbreaking what happened
and i love that they straight up said
like uh great britain left us with a
mess because that is what happened you
know the indian subcontinent was a
british colony and then there was a
separation in 1947
great britain left and then all of
society and the military the government
everything got divided on religious and
ethnic lines then it just displaced
millions of people and there's all this
ethnic violence where hindus and muslims
were just killing each other and it's
all just because britain just left i
mean it's just like a classic example of
like why colonization is bad because it
force it gives people uh the opportunity
to hate each other rather than just like
evolving on their natural course of
those societies getting to know each
other it forces one side to have more
power than they would have otherwise had
and then people are just cruel to each
other and this is why shuri called ross
a colonizer in black panther
all of that colonizing history
it's a mess and i'm glad that they
brought it up i really really love that
they are grounding uh kamala khan's
family history in that history and
that's tied to exactly how powers ended
up in her bloodline um they don't spell
it out yet though all we know so far is
that somehow her grandmother sana aka
hernani was able to make it back home to
her father after a a train station
separation by by following quotes a
trail of stars
what does that mean kamala's bengal at
this point invokes a vision of a female
ancestor uh and then afterwards kamala
calls nani and confirms that the bengal
belonged to aisha that was the name of
the great grandmother the start of the
family curse according to muniba and the
illuminati's so at this eat festival uh
kamala chats with the gospel illuminatis
this absolutely would be the group i
would be hanging out with at this point
i would just sit in the corner just
listen to their gossip and just like
like drop the tea auntie let's go
they're amazing i love these women so
much they tell kamala that aisha brought
a curse to the family uh some people
called her a snake that she might have
had a second family that she might have
killed a man
i forgot all these things are true i
think all these things are true
and then i think that she left the
planet and then became the aisha on the
sovereign plan
the very same emptiness
[Music]
story
while this is all happening dodc agents
cleary and dever interrogate zoe reveal
a bit of racial profiling in their
investigation even to clear he seems has
it in he's still just like we'll be
respectful but like dude dude
dude
like hey shut your racist magic out of
here it was like a classic racist
partner move it's like he's just used to
her being racist like all right just
don't hurt anybody at the boss please
he seems exhausted i think it was
sitting that he's probably going to say
something at some point this season
would be my expectation i guess we'll
see so kamala save some dopey kid from
scaffolding uh but another vision from
her ancestor causes her hard light to
flicker out the kid falls hurts his
ankle i already know it's my ankle
that's broken empty if you've ever hurt
your ankle do you know at that point
seconds later that you hurt your ankle
oh my oh my my tibia my oh my blindfold
oh my my
like back in the day at nickelodeon
shows it would be like my spleen it's
like
how do you know how do you know oh i can
feel everything
i know everything i can isolate each
part of my money
oh she's a villain she doesn't take a
picture of me turn into
everyone
deemer shows up with some
familiar-looking drones looks like those
might have been modded from some smart
drones confiscated during spider-man no
way home they also have some interesting
handheld weapons that look like some uh
some hulk propellers so you know we've
seen those from some star tech before uh
they tried to detain kamala but she's
like no smashy smash and then she uh
hops off the car she kind of hurts
herself but she's able to get past it
what a badass camaron shows up at just
the right time and then kamala's vision
woman sits in the back seat saying i've
been waiting a very long time to meet
you comrade says that's my mom and
kamala looks freaked out puking in her
mouth a little bit
and we got the black look at some some
questions does kamala and kamran
do they have a familial relationship who
exactly is this woman if she is an
ancestor why has she not aged if comrade
is related to kamala and if he knows
that why was he hitting on her camera
what are you doing hey man game of
thrones changed everyone
you're right
let me normalize no no no no we're gonna
clear it up for you uh but first head on
over to new rockstarsmerch.com check out
our latest obsession shirt cosmic
daydream inspired by the miss marvel
series like all of our latest obsession
designs this shirt is a limited edition
so once it is gone it will be harder to
get them kamala khan's driver's license
and when you purchase this shirt you'll
get the opportunity to unlock some uh
custom shout outs that will appear right
here on inside marvel let's see if we
got alyssa saying could ms marvel's
bengal have the same type of origin as
the 10 rings love you guys
empty you speculated that yeah it's
possible yeah i honestly feel like the
ten rings and the bengals could have
come from the same comet or meteor
rather that uh the vibranium came from
in wakanda so maybe um i think that
there's definitely a link there but what
do you think yeah i i think it's
possible i just think like uh i feel
like the writers rooms and the producers
are just a bit siloed on these different
properties and i uh think the origin
of them i would just be surprised if
they linked it to shanghi in particular
it seems like they're linking in other
directions but who knows uh i think it's
i think it's possible um i just think
like
i always default to whatever the term is
in the comics so i would say the ten
rings are mcclue and tech and i just
think
marvel kamala khan is cree tech uh but
i don't know we'll see nicholas asks if
the inhumans were introduced to the mcu
wouldn't they have to sign the sokovia
accords yeah i think the sokovia courts
are still in effect so legally yeah
every enhanced individual i think is
going to be prior to it's just like i
don't know did uh sam wilson and bucky
eventually sign the sokovia accords i
guess that was part of their terms of
their uh of their legal agreement with
the government um but we just don't know
for sure if they sign the sokovia
accords we just know that those are
still the law of the land yeah i think
that so i don't know if the humans would
be under it like the humans of um
attilan or adalan however you pronounce
it probably wouldn't be part of the
sokovia course because they're not a
part of the united nations but like
being humans in like america would
definitely probably have to sign it uh
because you can't be heroin
um against the law i mean the inhumans
on the moon they're not technically on
earth do these sakovia accords
jurisdiction extend beyond our
atmosphere i don't think so right i
don't think so i think it's only the
united nations um countries really
because like you can't really tell a
country that's not a part of the united
united nations what to do you can if you
colonize them empty
it's true
that's the trick
that's the colonization hack you could
be really cruel and imperialist and then
you can just do whatever you want we
have these uh theories coming out of
falcon winter soldier that cap was on
the moon at the time we're like is it on
the moon with the inhumans and is he
doing that so he doesn't have to sign
the scooby accords that old man doesn't
want to sign anything
people keep calling me confusing me
about trying to steal my bank
information i don't trust you
peggy
frankie you wake up a little bit
hey
oh no
kyle says let's hope you guys get a full
cannon mention love watching you guys
well thank you yes
fingers crossed it's coming someday
someday all right check out all of our
awesome virtual options grab this latest
obsession shirt over our new rockers
merch.com all right mt what's our first
question from this episode well our
first question eric is who is the woman
from kamala's visions in our kamala and
cameron related so um once we i did this
actress by the way is nimro abusha and
once we identify who her character is
and what she is
that's gonna be the same answer to what
kamala is in the mcu and what her powers
really are so the credits name this
character as najma in a jma and yes the
woman in that back seat has the same
exact appearance it's the same actress
as the woman from kamala's visions the
woman who reaches out to her from that
portal of light the light is purple
colored suggesting it's the same realm
that kamala initially dropped backward
into in episode one when her bangle
first activated the implication is that
this woman is one of kamala's ancestors
that's at least the implication it's
okay to interpret it that way but so
let's just first assume that najma could
actually be aisha that's kamala's
long-lost great-grandmother who we
learned quite a bit about in this
episode aisha was a family matriarch who
went missing during the partition of
india and pakistan in the late 40s the
illuminati spread rumors that aisha was
a snake had a second family that she
killed a man according to them aisha was
one who brought the curse upon the
family and that is why maniva feels the
shame why she fled to the united states
wanted a new start wants to keep kamala
grounded um and on the day that this
family separated during the partition
aisha mysteriously disappeared but it
seems like she helps her toddler sana
kamal's grandmother hernani reunite with
her father by using a trail of stars now
trail of stars could mean a lot of
things presumably it was something like
the lily pads of hard light that kamala
might have used definitely used to get
around that could have been something
that i used to use it uh the trail of
stars could have been a literal starship
belonging to asia's connections with the
inhumans or the krees or the skrulls um
hey it could have been a series of star
portals by america chavez my mind went
to that initially a trail of stars where
did we just see that in the mcu it's
just that'll be fun i would love to see
her up here in the show i'd be surprised
sochi gomez is showing up at all these
uh premieres i would just serious
i'm a utopian paralyzed but she keeps
showing up she does she truly is in a
multiverse that that woman right anyway
she's traveling it just sounds like the
superstition spread around aisha came
from the fact that she was an outsider
to that society either an
extraterrestrial living and hiding on
earth or an inhuman created by decree
using the process of pterogenesis and
then that dna passed down to kamala so
if the woman in the back seat is
actually aisha and if that is cameron's
mom too that would mean cameron is
kamala's grand uncle hopefully adopted
in that scenario because why would he
actively
that is creepy he is totally laying his
moves on her it's not just like showing
some platonic interest he's flirting
he's putting his hand on hers he's
putting his number in her phone he knows
what he's doing that's creepy if she is
aisha why has she not aged
well might because she's inhuman in
humans age slowly two to three times
slower than a normal human uh kamala had
a joke about looking younger than she
actually is like scott lang that could
be a tip that she has some inhuman dna
eternals also don't age there was a
reference to najma like in kingos movies
um but also after carol danvers got hit
with cosmic radiation received some cree
transfusions her aging was slowed down
so it could just be connected with that
and then of course we have super
soldiers in the mcu cap and bucky they
age more slowly there's also we should
point out in the x-men film continuity
certain mutants just randomly age more
slowly but really that was in the later
simon kinberg era of the franchise where
uh the characters from x-men uh first
class to age of uh or what's it called
apocalypse that's an apocalypse in the
dark phoenix it's like well i understand
why um mystique doesn't age but why is
hank mccoy still pretty young like
that age because
from the 60s to the 90s he looks the
same freaking age and it doesn't make
sense yes he has like injections or
whatever but like all of these
characters don't really age uh james
mcavoy he just gets bald but he still
looks just as young as he does in the
60s that's not a thing with mutants they
get older it's just wolverine doesn't
age because he has regeneration powers
they just really stretched a lot of the
stuff and i i don't know how many people
try to explain this to me on twitter it
doesn't make sense it's a plot hole shut
up i think the possibility of cameron
actually being related at least in this
episode is meant to be a jokey fake out
i think he's going to call back their
charade at the restaurant earlier i
think it's meant to freak her out this
is something that happens uh with large
extended families i can tell you growing
up in the south i've been to quite a few
family reunions and thank god and or
uncle say hey by the way that's your
cousin i'm like oh
oh
great
i know that now
oh boy all right well all right okay
okay okay great moving on thank you good
information to have
yes yes i think next episode we're going
to learn that this guy is either adopted
or that maybe maybe najma could actually
be a squirrel partner to aisha aisha
actually being passed away uh and that
you know squirrels just continued to
bear this resemblance and then she was a
friend of them and that's how squirrels
could be connected to this story maybe
we'll just learn that mom
mom is just comrade's affectionate term
for this uh other woman in his community
someone who raised him but it's not
really a biological connection it's just
this is just how the society is of
refugees is connected a society of
inhumans or creeds or scrolls maybe
mutants maybe something connected to the
eternals um but ultimately this episode
is confirmed that uh it confirms to us
that kamala's powers come from her dna
they do not come from the bangle and
that family bloodline has some kind of
cosmic link which is probably why moniba
used the word cosmic in episode one i
think she knows i think she knows that
it's something i think she's a secret
that she's not telling her daughter so
i'm just gonna quickly rank my uh
what i think is the likelihood of what
category of enhanced person kamala and
her bloodline are i think least likely
of the ones i've mentioned is eternals
just because aisha may have been aware
of what the eternals were like she knew
that something was going on with kango i
just doubt that marvel would categorize
kamala that way mcu eternals are defined
as synthetic alien custodians to doomed
planets there were one of 10 designs
from the celestials i don't think uh
kamal and her family are one of them um
a possible category i just think
unlikely would be mutant just because
these german enhancer and in the mcu
past like age of ultron enhanced his
code for in our code for mutant um
powers indeed with characters dna
inherited from the parents also kind of
code for mutant um i think marvel
studios might might use this opportunity
to find mutants in the mcu we are dying
to hear that word i just think all his
powers are described as cosmic with
language like trail of stars and while
some marvel mutants come from space like
the phoenix forest to define kamala's
mutant would confuse pretty much every
marvel fan chief among them iman valani
the way shape yes
i don't think she would like this one
like a man milani would not let her be
her become a mutant like she'd be like i
am a human black bolt is my father
like do not do this to me kevin
yes 100
possible possible category we could be
looking at a group of scrolls right
because secret invasion is coming i
think some of the characters in the
series are going to be revealed to
scrolls or at least girl connected you
know we know monica and rambo and carol
danvers uh
kamala's future co-stars are connected
with the scrolls they're hanging out
with scrolls nick fury's with this girls
agent cleary knows that
um the issue with squirrels is they do
not innately have any kind of ability to
project hard light unless they are a
super scroll in some way and i don't
think they're going to introduce scrolls
by starting with a super scroll you know
i think that would just be kind of like
a step too far uh we'll get there though
um to me the likeliest category is that
we're looking at cree tech and in human
uh pterogenesis so i know there is a
stigma among many marvel followers in
the past decade with the word inhuman
obviously with the drama with marvel tv
and jeff loeb snatching the title away
from kevin feige to replace his phase
three and move movie remember how he
announced that he was gonna do an
inhumans movie but then marvel tv
snatch it away from him to make this
failed abc series also a lot of marvel
comics fans are kind of like still uh
limping back from how the 2010s tried to
make inhumans popular instead of the
term mutants so that they could do them
as film and tv ip instead of x-men and
like the word fetch it didn't happen but
uh i think that putting black bolt in
multiverse of madness was a huge sign
that kevin feige is totally not afraid
of restoring inhumans to the mcu major
sign everyone who knows anything about
kamala khan from the comics it was a
huge popular comic series it made the
new york times bestseller won all these
awards and i don't think this is like
something from the distant past that
they're like oh we'll just change what
she is i think they're going to try to
stay faithful to those comics and i
think part of that is that she is an
inhuman created by createrogenesis and i
don't think it's controversial to call
her that in the mcu and i think most
signs of this series so far are pointed
in that direction dna alien tech that is
i mean that's cree tech right there my
friends i think and we've talked about
this before that kamal is still in the
cocoon we are watching the process of
terror genesis episode by episode and
she's shedding that cocoon and she's
going to have a new final form as the
directors have told us in our interview
with them like this is why like she said
what's it called amman valani said that
in a quote like i don't care if i had
sausage fingers for a power like all
that matters is the journey because
we're definitely on our way to a
pterogenesis moment where she gets those
um stretchy powers i feel but like i
don't want to say definitely we're
likely going there in my opinion yeah i
i agree i i think ultimately it's going
to be this or
equally likely it's just going to be a
new term like the mcu might avoid all of
the baggage from all these different
proper nouns and just create a new word
for whatever kamala and her ancestors
are
uh i just think ultimately we'll either
hear the word inhuman or we'll hear some
other new word that will just be like
okay but it's basically inhuman
yeah you know like either mutate like i
don't know one of those terms yeah i
don't think they'll say mutant i'd be i
would say sorry if they said anything
related to mutant because of all these
words mutant probably has the biggest
has the most baggage right
oh yeah for sure and like it's very
specific to the x gene the the whole
mutant thing so yeah i mean i wouldn't
be i wouldn't be bummed if they if they
did that uh i'm not going to object
right because we would understand but
like
i do want to see them dive into the
pterogenesis route and like for kevin
feige himself to use and to have to play
with the inhumans because like before
like you said uh those were jeff loebs
and humans so it was all the marvel tv
in humans which is why like there was a
a different type of quality no offense
to jeff lowe very great great guy um but
like you know if kevin feige has a very
specific vision you can tell a kevin
feige production versus anything else
like or a hulu production or whatever so
like yeah this is kevin feige's chance
of finally using the
inhumans the way that he wants you i
feel i think we're seeing a uh
a cosplay
um captain marvel fans version of
terogenesis i think i think what we're
gonna learn and this is at least what i
hope is the case is that terror genesis
looks different for every individual
it looks different from what is in their
inner heart's desires and that cocoon
takes a different form but ultimately it
is a a shell that the character sheds
off as they have a growing process over
a six episode series or something like
that you know like that's that's a more
fun way to do it the same way that the x
gene manifests in a different way for
every person and the power set is
different for every person i think
terogenesis is just a manufactured
version of that it comes from great
attack to where they they did genetic
experiments on humans and other
individuals to do this i think that's
ultimately what we're looking at and i
think uh i think the fact that
like who is najma ultimately i think it
is going to be
her uh her great-grandmother at least i
hope that's the case and she's just an
inhuman who hasn't aged that much uh i
hope camaron is adopted
i hope that i really hope so
that is uh that's my hope i i honestly i
think that um cameron and his uh mom are
using kamala and like playing her for
the bengal i i think that like cameron
doesn't care about kamala at all he's
just like i'm gonna say whatever i need
to say to get that bangle because uh
grandma sent it to the wrong sister
and uh we need that bagel for stuff oh
who do you think the right sister is
um well i think she wanted to give it to
kamala i think like the reason she sent
it was for kamal to get it because her
mother didn't wanted nothing to do with
the bangle she was like you know what i
know this was supposed to be mine but
like i don't want it so the grandma was
like all right screw you all right child
you wanted this for you
so you think that uh
all right so the moral alignment in your
opinion of of najma and kamran is
something like a lawful evil or chaotic
evil or something they're i think
they're doing sketchy [ __ ] because
cameron in the comics was like she
flirted with kamala to specifically
trick kamal into doing something for his
gain or for his gain in the end so like
i think that what this is what's going
on here cameron even though in the mc he
might be sort of good but at the end of
the day he's listening to his mom's
orders to manipulate kamala for the
bengal
um so i don't know my thinking is that
right now we're meant to distrust them
right because they've been lying and
they've been using her i think you're
right i think the reason for their
clandestine activities is to bypass
muniba
and i don't think muniba is like a
villain in any way but i think she is
holding kamala back out of fear out of
out of shame out of guilt for the way
she grew up and just like a
misinterpretation
misinterpretation of who her grandmother
was um in a fear that she's going to
lose kamala so i think that's
her worry um and that's going to i
always prefer antagonists that are
something like that you know they're
sympathetic and you completely get that
i think she's just an obstacle
ultimately i think the most villainous
character of this series is going to be
and already is diver right i think uh
the dodc is going to be revealed as some
kind of villain uh and i think
uh that kind of government enforcement
uh now we have seen in trailers there
are other characters who kamala is
fighting i think we're gonna learn about
them soon
um but uh i'm i'm still
you know i'm not gonna
i guess i should speculate on who they
are i mean
uh i think
decree right i think we're gonna learn
that like there whoever created these
inhumans on earth uh the cree sleeper
cell
uh i think created these genetic
experiments and kind of like super
soldiers who are created by nefarious
government entities i think these
inhumans are like we were caught in the
middle of this shadow war between korean
scrolls we didn't want to do that so now
we've had to go rogue and we just try to
help people but by helping people it
kind of made us outcasts in our
community uh but you now have this this
dna this bloodline that has uh a power
that gets unlocked by cosmic tech that
comes from right that we've stolen from
the cree but like you know what what do
you think about the the possibility
because like we learned at the end of
captain marvel that ronan was gonna come
back for the weapon meaning carol so
like what if ronan came back and started
was like all right carol's not here i
don't know where carol went let's just
mess around with these humans to like
make super people and uh maybe i mean
obviously like the it would be like
ronin came in the 90s so like he can't
make the bangle because the bengal has
been around for generations but what if
the splitter sell is ronin splinter cell
and like they've just been doing weird
[ __ ] like since the 90s i think that'd
be fun
yeah we uh we need we've met a lot of
the squirrel leadership right we need to
know the kree leadership we know uh
young rock we know the supreme
intelligence we know ronan ronan was a
disavowed militant from the kree society
during the
guardians of the galaxy so
yeah it could be him is he going to be
leading is he going to be the tip of the
spear in the shadow war with the scroll
i i think it's more likely they're going
to introduce another character uh uh
like someone else within the rankings
who's like the the commander the
five-star general of the korean military
i would love to see yon wrong if he was
really behind this too yeah because he's
a lot of pissed yeah so
uh i think we're going to meet the sl
the cree sleeper cells at some point uh
but i don't know if it's going to be
like one side versus the other side i
think there's just going to be a like in
any shadow war a lot of covert actors
who are uh taking matters in their own
hands it's gonna be messy and slop town
and that sounds
major messy
yeah all right let's thank some friends
who helped us make this episode of
starting with our friends at helix who
would think he looks for sponsoring this
episode of inside marvel i sleep on a
helix mattress and it's just what i need
after a night of staying up to watch
miss marvel helix sleep is a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect matches for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattresses great for uh spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq and wired magazine helix has
been recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep just go to
helixsleep.com inside marvel take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at elixsleep.com inside
marvel we also want to thank geology for
sponsoring this episode heroes have
superpowers but that does not mean they
don't need a skincare routine staying up
late to fight crime could leave bags and
circles under your eyes but superheroes
are not alone 50 of guys suffer from
under eye issues like dark under eye
circles puffiness tired eyes fine lines
and wrinkles that's where geology comes
in geology is a nine-time award-winning
men's skincare company recognized in
men's health esquire and askmen grooming
awards with over 5 000 5 star reviews
it's clear that people love this product
their skincare is built around just a
handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by dermatologists
for decades ingredients like retinol
niacinamide and kojic acid geology is
one of the only men's skin care
companies to have retinol as an active
ingredient in their products you click
the link provided you take 30 seconds
diagnostic quiz and with a few clicks
tell them about your skin and goals and
their team of dermatologists will design
a regimen just for you that's shipped
direct to your door head to geology.com
and take their free skincare quiz to
save up to 50 off your 30 days trial or
just click the link below that's
g-e-o-l-o-g-i-e
dot com or click the link below to stay
50 off your 30-day trial uh we also
thank manscape for sponsoring this
episode there's a certain confidence
that comes with being properly groomed
there's an aura a vibe you can just tell
by the way they carry themselves we call
this bge
big groomed energy
uh and there's just only one way to get
that bge and it's manscaped they just
rolled out their best hygiene bundle yet
it's called the platinum package 4.0
manscaped is a leader and below the ways
grooming now trust them with the rest
join the four million men worldwide who
trust manscape by going to manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code marvel manscape's brand new
platinum package 4.0 is the biggest
bundle they've ever offered giving you a
bulk discount on manscape's top products
inside this platinum package you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear nose and hair trimmer ultra premium
body wash ultra premium two in one
shampoo plus conditioner ultra premium
deodorant crop preserver anti-chafing
ball deodorant crop reviver ball spray
toner anti-shaving boxers the shed
travel bag to hold your goods while
traveling
and you can now completely upgrade your
shower routine with the ultra premium
body wash and ultra premium two in one
shampoo plus conditioner you'll have
your skin and hair feeling hydrated and
spelling fresh get 20 off and free
shipping with the code marvel at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use the code
marvel unlock your big groomed energy
with manscape to remember when you trim
the hedges the tree stands taller
empty back to this episode of inside
marvel i want to ask for the dodc i
speculated that they're going to be the
ultimate villain of this series and that
agent clear he will never come to jesus
moment might he might reveal himself as
a scroll and say you know what i was
doing this is the cover but these guys
are f'ed up i want to ask it seems like
they might return in she-hulk and secret
invasion what do you think i definitely
feel like the dodc is like the the new
like secret sketchy organization of the
mcu so yeah i definitely feel like
they're gonna appear in she-hulk for
sure because we know that she-hulk is
going to deal with this uh prison that
deals with these super-powered villains
that they keep um locked up tight so uh
damage control definitely has to have
some type of relationship with them in
my opinion so like we'll see them there
i feel and also secret invasion deals
with uh alien threats and um that's what
the damage control sort of deals with
like the the aftermath of the chitauri
invasion all of that so like that's
definitely in damage control's um
uh purview but i also feel like we're
gonna see them in armor wars for sure in
my opinion because like um they're they
have that whole vault i can't stop
thinking about the vault especially
after this episode where we see them
using mysterio's drones after they they
confiscated the glasses in no way home
so like they're they're definitely using
all this technology that they're they're
taking to their own uh advantage and i'm
wondering if they're using that ultron
tech because we saw my ultron head in
homecoming um i wonder if ultron is
being utilized by the dodc as well which
would be a bad idea don't do that
because uh
yeah i think the dodc is uh the one
running that prison facility with
abomination in it i think they're just
gonna be like considered the earthbound
uh government agency that's in charge of
all this stuff and then sword will be
the uh atmospheric slash cosmic slash
spacebound version of it um but like
i mean my theory is that the dodc is
like a front organization for all the
scrolls on earth like their job is to do
witness protection for all the scrolls
there's got to be some screening of the
otc for sure yeah in fact maybe all of
them are squirrels maybe all of them are
yeah maybe that that that woman from uh
judging amy who was in homecoming she
might be at school
uh that guy they brought back the actor
in hong kong he got punched in the face
he was standing right behind cleary in
no way home that guy's scroll they're
all scrolls yes
damage control department of damage can
scroll if you just look real closely at
it and stand at the side
that control is actually t-r-o-l no that
says
s-k-r-u-l-l-o i'm telling you i'm
telling you i'm telling you it's
confirmed it is confirmed we are going
to defy encanto right now and talk about
bruno no no no no no what is bruno's
future is he going to caltech or will he
want to stay close at home and go to mit
where he could meet iron hearts and he
could meet ned and mj
and he could uh meet everybody
uh
he could be part of the mcu in future
because this guy is brilliant he's a
great engineer he's going to be working
for stark industries he's going to meet
amadeus cho
what's going to happen to bruno like i
would love to see him go to imit and
like meet up with uh mj and uh ned it
would be really fun to see like the
crossing overs um but i think that
bruno
he just likes kamala too much and so
he'll probably end up going to wherever
kamala ends up going which is
kind of
i know it's it's kind of wet because
like he's a super smart dude and he
should definitely go to caltech because
like why not like that's good for your
future but like you know we know that
bruno is like a mainstay in the uh miss
marvel comics so like wherever mrs
marvel ends up going he's probably gonna
go as well but i feel like mit would be
so great i would love to see ms marvel
and him in boston they tease boston in
no way home come on over to boston we
have so much crime
going on unanswered please come
no sleep till boston i think exactly the
uh i think he's gonna end up working for
sword i think he's gonna be like the
chief head of technology here head of
the science division of sword i think
that's the best place for him working
right underneath abigail brand you know
that's that's where he belongs or maybe
bruno is a skrull too we don't know we
don't know well we see them he has this
tech that can um analyze the the
energies within kamala it'd be really
cool if like he sort of picked up uh
marvel's work sort of uh at shield or
whoever picks up marbella's work made in
that sword i think that sword is perfect
because like they have goose and like
all of that so like yeah i feel like
yeah sword is such a good idea i didn't
even consider that
empty i have to ask you
why does bruno have that app on his
tablet like
did he pick that up in the past 24 hours
i don't think so i think he had it like
if you know if kamala got to look at
that tablet she's like why is there a
column for when my menstrual cycle is
improved
for science
or something i guess he's doing some
sketchy [ __ ]
bruno this has like all of my locations
for the past two weeks and it knows when
i woke up why is there a camera feed in
my bathroom bruno
why does this floppy dick say uh project
inside bruno
[Laughter]
bruno why does this have a list out of
every outfit i've worn for the past
month you know
bruno why are you keeping a log of like
every all of my smells bruno every time
you smell me it's like she wore uh lilac
perfume today
burrito's a stalker which is why i
kamala wants nothing to do with them i
understand kamala it's all good just be
keep everyone we need to keep an eye on
bruno i'm just saying yes we need to
talk about it
[Laughter]
just keep an eye on that one maybe
getting over to the west coast is the
best thing for bruno get them far away
yes
like if anyone is going to uh revive
ultron it's going to be bruno i'm
telling you we're just kidding around
bruno we love you bruno we would never
it's okay we love you it's going to be
fine he's going to get molly in the end
i hope get that smooch it's just we need
to make sure that the projects he's
working on are just some wholesome nice
uh society contributing
uh technology because you know with the
wrong motivation i want i want bruno to
to make big wheel though
the spider-man villain big wheel i
wanted to design the big wheel
i want him to be big wheel
oh my god anyway
we got to get out of here emt we're
being too hard on this character uh but
that's it for this episode of inside
marvel again the breakdown's coming out
later today and stay tuned get some fun
easter eggs
little sneaky eggs little sneaky stinky
eggs hiding everywhere
this is from last easter why does it
smell so bad in the bathroom oh it's an
egg that we forgot to get it's there i
don't know kamala left it in the
bathroom last night right and
uh bruno knew all about it bruno didn't
say anything that was on his table he
didn't say [ __ ]
uh don't forget to check out our great
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow mt and
mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching we'll see you
next week yes thank you
bye
you